love him or hate him Andrew Tate is an
absolute genius in the span of a few
months Andrew Tate went from practically
nothing to Apparently one of the most
searched people on the planets Tick Tock
videos using his hashtag reviewed more
than 14 billion times he was everywhere
all the time in a way no other
influencer has been before him he went
from you know relatively unknown to I
think on everyone's radar within six
months and I mean everyone's radar and
Andrew take took all this attention and
turned it into 60 million dollars in
less than a year according to our
estimates but it goes much further than
just views and money Andrew Tate now has
true influence true power over the most
consequential demographic there is Young
military age males how much influence
you ask enough to get his followers to
change their religion I think if you
control the medium you control the
message I think if you have an affiliate
Army that'll say whatever you want and
you can instruct them to put out
whatever piece of podcast content you
want and you're getting billions of
views you control reality I've got you
know addition are following on Instagram
and Tick Tock and you know I've got this
young kid who engages with me from time
to time I know he's a big Tate fan
um and he's kind of been going off the
rails lately right getting him more into
the conspiracy stuff and all that so
I've been trying to settle him down just
you know hey kid you need to be sleeping
you need to be eating right and he's you
know basically asking me for
self-improvement advice because he can't
do anything other than push-ups and
praise Allah and so he's he's converted
to Islam as well with with Tate and this
is a this is like a white American this
is a 16 year old you know lives at home
suburb white American and like in rural
Ohio like you know didn't know what
anything about the Islamic faith until
he saw it take convert a couple weeks
ago so basically what you're saying is
uh like Tate's influence like he's
figured out this way to influence the
masses so effectively that like he has
real power now yeah like a white teenage
boy in America
converted to Islam
we'll do whatever he says that's right
that's pretty powerful
extremely powerful
young military age males are the ones
that go to war that start a revolution
that toppled those in power and Andrew
Tate now has them in the palm of his
hand this is my good friend Rob Oliver
by the way he's found seven different
multi-million dollar e-commerce Brands
which made him obsessed with propaganda
and the mechanics of how to influence
the masses so he really helped out with
this video I'll link to his socials
below definitely follow him and this was
no accident by the way now this was a
carefully thought out strategy that
Andrew Tate probably put a lot of
thought into that we're gonna call the
tape model an insanely genius yet simple
system where you have your Die Hard fans
flood the internet with clips of
yourself promoting your products and
then you pay them a commission for every
sale thus creating this beautiful
profitable self-reinforcing cycle of
attention and money mixed reviews on the
color some people like it someone
said well what color is your Brigade
Andrew Tay has forever changed the game
of business marketing influencers and
propaganda forever I'll take it one
further than business marketing I think
he fundamentally shook the fabric of
like all of organized Society even super
PG influencers like Mr Beast are taking
a page out of his Playbook I just want
to do more podcasts because a lot of
people really upload them on Tick Tock
and stuff like that so it's like even if
this hypothetically got we'll just say a
million views it could get hundreds of
millions of views on Tick Tock if we
just say some cool [ __ ] it's a great
time to do a bunch Kate kind of like
started that too yeah I would call it
the tape model and in this video we're
gonna put aside all the drama and we're
gonna break down the Andrew Tate model
step by step in all its glory for you to
replicate if you so choose my name is
Jake Tran stay dangerous subscribe for
more and let's get into it
[Music]
foreign
and by the way Rob just launched a new
brand called Alpha grind guys I cannot
recommend this stuff enough I woke up
with like five hours of sleep today I
was feeling super low super sluggish
took some of this one to an hour in Muay
Thai with some light sparring then an
hour of strength of conditioning right
after and who I just felt so in the zone
wide awake so much like mental Clarity
in my brakes felt super super sharp I
was able to trade super aggressively I
was able to really push my limits and I
still have energy like literally right
now to start working on YouTube so yeah
super amazing stuff what this is is a
combination of coffee and nootropics and
if you don't know what New Tropics are
they're legal supplements that make your
brain feel sharper smarter just more
mental Clarity you just feel like in the
zone I take these Tropics almost every
day but now what alphabet I get a super
clean smooth energy boost too from the
caffeine coffee usually makes me super
jittery but this is super clean and
super smooth
put it in
drink up
and you're good to go so yeah I cannot
recommend this enough and Rob is giving
you guys 20 off with the coupon code 20
Jake Tran with the link below most
YouTube sponsors only get like 10 off so
20 off is super good check it out with
the link below and get it right now
thanks to Alpha grinding Rob for
sponsoring this video
before he became the most controversial
guy on the internet Andrew Tate was a
legit four-time world champion kickboxer
and while he was still fighting he
started building a little audience on
Twitter I mean he had been on the
internet for a long time so it wasn't
like he had just you know like just
started on the internet and all of a
sudden took over he he originally was on
Twitter kind of in that whole manosphere
so you know dating masculinity the whole
the whole red pill movement that was
that was his thing and then he was
largely attached to Trump and so he was
kind of just an aggressive troll on
Twitter and built built you know a
pretty hardcore following some really
good connections with kind of the OG
Twitter audience and what what time
period was this was this during like his
kickboxing phase or was it after or yeah
it's my understanding he was on Twitter
like very early on as early as like
2014. but it wasn't really going
anywhere so he tried something else to
get more Fame reality TV in 2016 he went
on a reality show called Big Brother and
proceeded to get kicked off six days
later after after a video surface of him
hitting a woman with a belt Tate and the
woman said it was consensual but it
didn't matter he was out but what seemed
like a setback in the moment made Tay
realized something that would forever
change the course of his life doing
super controversial things makes you go
viral super fast a simple but very
profound truth so he leaned into it his
twist got more controversial he started
gaining a little bit more traction on
the side he set up a webcam business
that made him his first Millions but the
growth was just not fast enough and it
was around this time that Tick Tock
started blowing up and it was a game
changer all of a sudden literally anyone
could go viral and become famous on a
scale never seen before while posting
low production quality videos that
didn't take a lot of effort to make and
that's when Tate noticed something
interesting not only did controversial
content go even more viral on Tick Tock
compared to any other platform but he
also noticed a word pattern where the
very first Tick-Tock you post on a new
account always seemed to go viral maybe
you've noticed this too it's happened to
a bunch of people we know whether very
first takeout they post is not very good
but without fail the first one always
seems to go viral why probably to get
people addicted to making tick tocks and
the executives at Tick Tock don't know
what the masses are gonna enjoy so why
not it costs Tick Tock practically
nothing to give everyone a shot to see
what viewers like the most so that got
Tate thinking if new accounts get
rewarded on Tick Tock and controversial
contest spreads even faster on there if
he could get an army of people to post
clips of him saying the most
controversial Outlander stuff all on new
tick tock accounts he would have the
potential to go viral like no one ever
has before the problem was even if
you're a die-hard Andrew Tate fan why
would you waste hours of your life
finding clips of him adding captions on
the screen posting them on Tick Tock in
perpetuity unless you had some kind of
incentive and it was right then and
there that Andrew Tate realized what he
needed to do he needed to provide his
fans some kind of incentive to post as
many controversial Clips as possible and
what better incentive than a monetary
incentive enter Hustler's University
[Music]
in 21 Andrew Tate launched Hustler's
University at first it was just a course
on how to make money dating tips and
advice on how to escape the matrix but
then in late 2021 the program underwent
a pretty big change and relaunch as
Hustlers University 2.0 overall the
aesthetic and production quality of
hustlers University leaves a little bit
to be desired but if you're a teenage
boy that doesn't know anything about
making money the education was actually
pretty decent definitely better than
nothing and here's how it works for 49 a
month you got to choose to learn one of
seven different ways to make money
online from crypto to freelancing to
copywriting to drop shipping and more
whatever pathway you chose you would get
access to all sorts of lessons from
Tate's hand-picked professors and it was
all hosted in a Discord server where you
and the community of students could
discuss how to stop being a wage slave
Brooke
and how to become a financially free top
G I'm the only real G and guess what one
of those money making Pathways you could
choose from was a little section called
affiliate marketing it was pure genius
if you were a student that chose this
path you would learn all about affiliate
marketing how to Market other people's
products and get paid a commission for
every sale you got now you may be
thinking but that's great and no Mr
topchi but what product should I
affiliate Market first well you're in
luck young student because we have the
perfect product for you to Market
Hustler's University where you're gonna
get paid a fat 25 commission per sign up
or 50 of the first month of the new sign
of subscription and no you don't get any
money if your sign up sign up other
people so it's not on MLM oh what you
still don't know where to start you
don't know how to market the course
that's okay because here's a Google
Drive containing all the podcasts and
clips of every controversial thing I've
said on camera all organized out for you
here are specific instructions on how to
edit these clips in the tick tocks and
how to add captions by using a free
online video editor from canva.com here
are instructions on how to to create a
tate Tick Tock fan page here's a
template to create a high converting
landing page with a bunch of screenshots
of students making money from Hustlers
University with their own affiliate link
attached all using a free landing page
tool called beacons.ai oh you don't have
screenshots of other students making
money you're not just head over to the
HD wins channel in discordant where all
the students post screenshots of their
wins in fact here's everything a 15 year
old boy with no social media experience
would need to have to create a viral
Andrew Tate fan page on Tick Tock by
intentionally posting the most
controversial clips of me as possible
and what this genius affiliate program
in place once Andrew Tate got a few good
Affiliates working for him that is when
he blew up
foreign
[Music]
specifically taught his Affiliates that
attracting controversy was the quote key
to success End quotes and that they
should be aiming for 60 fans and 40
haters because quo you want arguments
you want war end quotes basically you
want to post the most outlandish Clips
out of context to drive up engagement
and create a war in the comments section
the worst thing women do is they Flex
now that I'm rich now that I'm top g
king of the world what made Tate's
affiliate content and Direction so
effective was he didn't just hand them
you know like this General blueprint and
say remake all my content it was no take
the piece of the content where I slap
and tell her to shut right and start
with that lead with that it'll get
someone to stop scrolling and so they
were very intentional on finding the
most inflammatory aggressive material
because it's what works once the
Affiliates posted the eclipse The Tick
Tock algorithm would do what it does
best there was there was a lot of old
stuff on his YouTube that I believe got
it off the ground and so I know they
repurposed a lot of that I'm sure you
had a lot of his actual team you know
cranking out content repurposing it on
Tick Tock taking these swings at that
how instrumental was like Tick Tock it
was everything you couldn't have done
this otherwise like Tick Tock is this
equalizer that has fundamentally changed
all social media for everyone and no one
appreciates it yet but it is we've all
been conditioned on you know Instagram
and Twitter like all the historic
platforms to think our follower account
is what matters right the more followers
the more important we are and tick
tock's really the opposite like they
want as many people on there creating
content and using the platform and so
they reward early accounts that's what
Tate realized he says screw what was
let's adapt to what is and I think
that's where the the genius came to be
he never even made an account for the
first year and from there the money
started rolling in for both Tate and his
Affiliates the best Affiliates will
start raking in some insane money one
affiliate earned 11 000 in just one week
for just having an Andrew Tate fan page
it was insane and we're pretty sure that
there were Affiliates that made much
more than Lots some of them made stupid
money like there was there was one kid
who was pulling in like 40 or 50
thousand dollars a month and once the
snowball started gaining momentum Tate
just reinvested into the flywheel he
started jumping on more and more
podcasts why are we not equal I'll tell
you why we're not equal biologically
we're not equal we're fresh and fit to
full sent for the longest period of
human history men had more than one
woman he would go on and say the most
outrageous stuff possible to give his
army of Affiliates more ammo to play
with he would reinvest the money into
more Bugattis and stuff to show off in
more videos and by June 2022 Hustlers
University ballooned to over 55 000
students that's 2.7 million a month a
month later T had around 80 000 students
or 3.9 million dollars by August over
160 000 students or 8.1 million dollars
in a month at that time Andrew Tate
didn't even have an official Tick Tock
accounts but videos using hashtag Andrew
Tate have been viewed more than 10
billion times and then
an eye Andrew Tate was canceled and
banned on all platforms I got a strike
on YouTube which prevented me from
posting the next day met up took me down
deleted my Facebook and my Instagram
um the Press came out at exactly the
same time in sync saying that I'm a
misogynistic dangerous person that I'm
harmful that I am the reason that the
world is not a perfect place world
hunger you name it all my fault a few
hours before the YouTube strike expires
guess what happens they abandoned feet
then they Banned Me from Discord then
they banish Airbnb they Banned Me from
stripe they ban I can't even remember it
was just emails coming in faster than
you could believe
the following month there was a big dip
in students in Hustlers University but
just a month later in October 2022
Hustler's University was bigger than
ever at 220
000 students that's 11 million dollars
in a month even with them getting
canceled Andrew Tate has made history
and he's ushered in a new era of
propaganda I went to this party my
friend as a jet I was in this Lambo and
you're just like shut there's nothing
less attractive
[Applause]
you know propaganda was originally a
term coined by Edward Bernays you can
think of it as public relations today
like he he was writing the book on
Modern Corporation public relations and
propaganda was the word he used and it
was basically a way to subtly influence
the masses to do what you think is best
for society Edward Bernays had an
ethical code like he helped influence
smoking you know for for women and then
he found out smoking was bad and you
know helped disband that whole messaging
but to him it was a way to influence
Society in a non-violent collaborative
way in an effective way and that all
changed in you know after World War II
it got a negative connotation and it was
just rebranded as as public relations
and so up until recently really you know
social media has started to to change it
across the board before Tick Tock even
like you know Twitter fake news on
Facebook et cetera et cetera but the
means of propaganda was just controlling
the the message right the medium is the
message that was a marshall mcluhan you
know term way back in the day but
um basically if you had enough money or
you had control of the institutional
systems you could cultivate whatever
narrative you want and whether that
meant getting a doctor you know on the
radio telling everyone that you know
bacon is a good breakfast food
or if it meant you know
putting ads out that women smoking made
them sexy like that was traditional
propaganda and
that's all it changed it was restricted
to like people with a lot of money big
corporations you needed serious
resources before social media you needed
serious resources like you were running
National ads at first it was print ads
then it moved to TV you know and so the
only people that could play in those
games were usually multinational
corporations
and that's how it worked and I don't
view propaganda as a Bad Thing per se I
see it as a way of influencing people's
behavior and you look at all the young
men now all of a sudden that because of
his propaganda like they're waking up
like they're trying to take control of
their lives they're trying to work out
they're not afraid to talk to women like
it's a fundamental attack of what
historically was going on from like a
Global Perspective one guy with an
iPhone can reach billions of people with
whatever message they want and like that
was already a thing like the average
person can like now reach more people
but Tate basically took that and just
like Amplified it by like a thousand X
Kate exploited Tick Tock to a thousand
acts because social media was the first
great equalizer right like Instagram and
and all of that was like the first it's
like oh we can use influencers now to
push our message and then that kind of
Consolidated and it became who has the
most money but still you know kind of a
traditional game and then Tick Tock and
Tate just busted It Wide Open you can
reach tens of billions of people with
whatever message you want so basically
he was able to achieve the same thing uh
that multinational corporations spend
billions of dollars to achieve more
effectively because they spend that
money in their message still falls apart
sometimes and again now he's got kids
converting to Islam and thinking Dubai
is the greatest place in the earth
basically if you want Power you have to
sway the masses traditionally display
the masses you relied on giant TV ad
campaigns newspapers things that you
know were part are part of like the
quote-unquote Matrix like like take
talks about
I think it's gonna cost like hundreds of
millions of dollars uh but now you can
or you sell your soul right like yeah
yeah but now you can achieve the same
thing you can sway the masses
with whatever beliefs you want
just through this model of the tape
model that's absolutely right that's
absolutely right he he achieved in a
year what took Drake a decade what are
my overall thoughts on Andrew's age look
I think he accelerated what needed to be
accelerated I think he was a net
positive for like so many young men in
this world who have been kind of cast
aside and that no one talks about he
basically found this whole audience of
like the people no one cares about and
he empowered them and if we want a
better tomorrow if we want a better
future if we want you know a
pro-capitalistic entrepreneurial
Innovative Society you need engaged and
excited young men and so I'll never say
anything bad about him because I think
he woke up an entire generation that you
know they're spending less times on
their phones they're taking
responsibility for their life
um so I don't have anything bad to say
and I think he should be I think he
should be back on the internet and now
you're already starting to see other
influencers model his system and for
your convenience here's a step-by-step
guide as to how
[Music]
foreign
first you need a product Tate went with
the tried and true online course
teaching people how to make money but it
doesn't have to be that it can be almost
anything I'm sure if Mr Beast really
wanted to he could do this with his
chocolate bars
um do you think it has to be
specifically a course on how to make
money oh no absolutely not absolutely
not I'm doing something very interesting
so follow me for more and if you want to
make money young kids but no no it
translates to anything let's say Mr
Beast wanted to implement this
realistically he could do it by just
offering like affiliate
uh Commission on his chocolate bars yeah
for sure you just need something that
will sell and therefore something you
can offer an affiliate program for then
you just need some ammo for your
Affiliates to play with hosting or
getting on podcast is the most efficient
way to do this obviously the more
controversial stuff you say the better
but it doesn't have to be that
controversial to work it has to it has
to work on the platform so it has to
like what it has to do is have to get
people to stop scrolling and it has to
get people to care enough to engage like
those are the two criterias it has to
check just look at how Joe Rogan and Mr
Beast have a bunch of people making
clips of them even though they don't say
anything too controversial and they
don't even have an affiliate program
either they just have super super
die-hard fans that want to build an
audience off of their Fame and now that
you have your product the affiliate
program and the contents now it's time
to create step-by-step instructions for
your Affiliates to follow the easier you
make the instructions the more resources
you give them the more successful
Affiliates you're gonna have that was
like a good offer they had a viable path
to making money you had kids probably
never made a dime who worship all the
internet gurus who all of a sudden could
be making I mean what 200 bucks a month
is like you know great to them and so
there was the right market and the right
incentive what I'm pretty sure of is you
have to be willing to take the time and
put the system together to educate
people and in relative detail especially
now as it's getting harder like because
I've tried some very like half-assed
stuff and it I forget how you know no
disrespect to gen Z but the average 16
year old is not smart enough to like
think through it all was Discord super
important in this whole scheme yeah
Discord was on base right and and that's
where this younger generation lives and
so it was the right place to host them
you couldn't have done this in a
Facebook group The Way Discord was
organized it worked on that younger
generation
and then boom if you do it right the
money and attention will start
exponentially growing on its own or if
you don't want to set any of this up
yourself and you're just looking for an
affiliate program like this that you can
promote with all the resources and
step-by-step instructions that we just
talked about I'm launching my own course
with my own affiliate program just like
this but the commission is going to be
way higher than Hustler's University a
hundred dollars per sign up instead of
25 and in my humble opinion I think my
course is way more unique and better
than Hustler's University in a different
way no offense to Andrew with 20 plus
lessons all narrated by me in the same
documentary style you've come to love
and to kick off this launch and for the
holidays use code tape for 20 off
expires at the end of the year we're
probably not going to do a sale this big
again for a while so use it while you
can click the link below to sign up to
be an affiliate now what you thought I
just did all this research just for your
convenience this is for my education too
and now we all get the benefits see
after researching all the videos on this
channel about how the world really works
I saw a very startling pattern all the
wealthiest countries in the world all
the wealthiest corporations in the world
all the richest people in the world they
produce nothing the West doesn't produce
anything the West doesn't do any of the
hard labor Apple doesn't manufacture the
iPhone no Asia Africa Latin America do
all the hard labor for us and yet for
some reason the West has all the wealth
all the power while the majority of Asia
Africa and Latin America have been stuck
in poverty this seems like it's almost
by design that they've stayed poor and
that's when it clicks the most powerful
people and institutions today have all
the wealth not because they do all the
work only suckers do the hard work no
they have all the power because they
figured out how to enslave the rest of
the world to do the work for them and
I'm not talking about traditional
slavery with whips and chains I'm
talking about the most sophisticated
form of slavery the world has ever seen
Financial slavery see the world has
always ran on slavery just ask the Roman
Empire but back then you needed an
entire standing army to go out and
Conquer a territory to enslave its
people to use Azure cheap labor force
but today you can enslave entire
populations with lone Sovereign debts
and a smile on your face see it's no
longer physical Warfare but Financial
Warfare instead of capturing a
city-state and enslaving its people you
simply open up sweatshops for pennies on
a dollar you open up factories with
suicideness to prevent your slaves I
mean workers from killing themselves
today is no longer called slavery that
has a bad ring to it it's called
inconspicuous names like globalization
or offshort but it's slavery all the
same and up until recently this modern
day form of slavery used to be only
reserved in the most powerful Nations
and corporations but thanks to the
internet you can take advantage of the
same exact power and I expose all of
this in my new program called Financial
Warfare masterclass
with 20 plus lessons all narrated by me
in the same documentary style you've all
come to love use Cote for 20 off it
expires at the end of the year they're
super addicting to watch super
binge-worthy you'll learn what the world
has been hiding from you all along and
we'll go over exactly how you can
implement this stuff to make more money
even if you're an employee right now or
don't even have a job and yes there is
an affiliate program where as of right
now you get a hundred dollars per sign
up instead of 25. there's a 14 day
refund policy too so scroll down and
click the link below to buy it now
[Music]
foreign
[Music]